I'm gonna take this equation top top most one this
one.
Bring it into box map and I will break down the terms for you.
so
this is moment.
And this is the formula.
so
if I break once we break this down, it will be so much
easier for you to
make sense of the
of you know
the language
so
this all we've covered so far moment.
And here is that formula.
Okay.
How many terms we have here? One, two, three one three we have three and
then the third one has a couple of more.
mu
Is what this is the population mean?
Remember that Greek letter talks about the population.
population mean
e of x
Is the expected value?
expected value
Okay.
e of x
Is the expected value?
But I told you that expected value is the
same thing as the mean.
Mean expected value are the same idea. Why does then?
Why do we have two different terms mean?
Is this is a general idea expected value applies
to the random valuable specifically?
Like you ideally you wouldn't say the mean of the random variable you would
see the expected value of the random variable.
So we have mu and E of x.
Make both me the same thing. Okay now mule can
mean the
Population mean of the data set it can only be the population
mean of the random variable. But if you were talking about the population mean of
the random variable you would call it expect value. Sorry for
the mouthful, but again terms are super important.
And then we have this guy.
the summation notation
summation notation
let me
copy this here this this portion of the
equation
put that in here.
And as if I think everyone knows what somebody's notation means
it just means that you take this term.
And he added up.
Several times. So for example, we have
the
X is the random variable bar X means the size of X. So for example,
if you have five members in the random variable, then this summation notation
would add this expression.
this expression five times
so if we take let's break down this summation notation
some more e just the letter just the letter
e
just a letter e or more specifically e to the power x corresponds to
the macular and series.
McLaren series is a geometric series.
And it's it's one of its applications in is
in approximating a number.
You can get a very close approximation the closest possible approximation.
Is achieved by Computing the McLaren series?
Now, why do we have t and X?
Okay, I want to avoid getting into tea.
because if I get into tea that's going to explode into
a different discussion and that getting into eat
the power T, which makes sense when we
get into Workshop 2, but just know that e to the power x
that is equivalent to the macaron series, which I have typed out
here.
Let's just say this is McLaren.
series
Okay, and P of X, you know what that is.
This is the probability for any given.
value in the random variable
So X.
sub, I
it's just the value within the random variable.
value
within the random variable. So for example, remember the the seat assignment.
the seats in the airplane
s122 whatever 5 would be one seat.
in all of the airplane
this would be
What do we call this?
value
in
random variable
and of course, we all should know by now that the random variable is
written with a big letter x
essentially what you're doing is this
you're at you you are.
taking
and approximation of a value
of a random variable multiplying it with
it's probability.
And you're doing this expression you're
doing this.
You know mathematical expression.
as many
for as many times as there are values in the random
variable. That's that's what summation notation means.
Okay, take the value in the random variable.
Multiply it by is probability. But let's just do the first moment
and it will go the first moment. Like I told you this Mew means
population me a population mean
and
if you want to compute the population mean that means you're calculating the
first moment.
or you have X
and that just means that you take
in this for the first moment T will be equal to
0.
As a matter of fact for discrete values
T will always be equal to 0 so even you should not even
see this.
T is only useful
for continuous random variables
so for example
This is what summation notation means for those who need to
remember so much notation is so basically take this portion this expression.
Okay, and he added up.
For example, if random variable has five values you added
up five times. So that's one.
and then two
and then you go on and not until you have five of these that's what
this summation notation means.
So for example, if you want to calculate here, we have
a probability distribution, right?
X is 0 1 2 3 so 4.
Items in the random variable so you would have to do this expression.
How many times four times?
For the first moment.
Okay.
for discrete random variables
T will always be to equal to zero
and I haven't typed out.
the the derivative of e of
x
if you have a discrete random variable.
You will ultimately end up with this expression.
So for example that e
to the power, for example, what's the first x value
it will be zero.
okay, so this would be this this x
would be zero this x would be one this x would be
the last X would be
okay.
now when you take the derivative
of e to the power 0 remember because we're talking
about discrete random variables e to the power 0 we would
have e to the power 0 but then e to the power zero is
just one.
E to the power is just one.
so
when we evaluate
this
expression
e of T disappears entirely and all we left with is
x times the probability. That's what we have here. This
is the first x times the first P of x.
This is the first this is the second
x times the second P of x.
Third x third P of X and so on and then you get the probability.
Excuse me, you get the you get the mean?
You get the population mean?